hi Josh so I have to say this is
starting off as one of my favorite
episodes you've given us wine seems to
be a pretty expensive one but very good
wine
it's not bad right it's a more sand the
varietal so we normally don't as we were
saying but you know we normally don't
pour this much wine in a glass at one
time but you know for podcast reasons
not to go back and forth with the bottle
you know yeah we were instructed to make
sure it's already full as we begin
although I was expecting a wine glass
full of breast milk
you know we can make some coffee and you
know use that as like the the creamer
yeah okay you need to walk me through I
know that you've told us a little bit
about how we got to the trying breast
milk conversation but I need a
play-by-play so that's how we got there
and then also why you decided to tweet
about it
so I'll say
every I'll start with I'll start my
response or explanation with I would say
85 of new dads at least wonder what
breast milk tastes like right so I
wasn't I was I wondered I'm like I
wonder what it actually tastes like Etc
I was like I'm not gonna taste it you
know what I mean so
we had family over in that day
um and they asked me they're like did
you have you tried saying I'm like no I
haven't tried it and I was just joking
on like if I ever try it you know so the
family asked yeah so and that was like
nah but if I ever do you know I want the
whole the whole you know the whole Shira
I want to be burped I want to be cradled
I want I want I want everything so
um that was the conversation for like
five ten minutes and then somehow I got
finessed into doing like a blind tasting
so we had like almond milk a couple
flavors of almond milk uh uh a creamer
and and that and breast milk
um so they like blindfolded me
um and I was I was trying to different
ones and
um
I tried it obviously and it was it was
like vanilla flavored almond milk that's
how it tasted okay well you're
blindfolded do you have a taste test you
have like all these cups in front of you
and you're just seeing which is which
and then they said which one tastes the
best or which one do you think is breast
milk which one you think is breast milk
um and it was the last one I tasted and
I was like I literally took the
blindfold off after I taste I'm like
damn I'm like damn this is actually like
it doesn't taste bad I was like this
gotta be the breast milk and like I just
knew because like it tasted the best out
of all of them and I was like I know
this was probably the breast milk
because I heard it's like some people
say it tastes like like sweet almond
milk
um and that's how it that that's how it
was and then I would just like you know
I'm just I'm gonna tweet and just see
what people think so like I think people
think like I'm out here just like
indulging in almond milk 24 7. you wake
up in the morning glass is ready shout
out to Shannon
you know uh that's not it you know it
was just like uh probably not even like
uh wasn't even like a shot glass full
album I mean uh breast milk but
um
yeah I don't know it wasn't bad I'll say
that I will say this is what I thought
was interesting
Darren and CJ did not deny that they had
tried it
so I I'm telling you every dad or mostly
every dad at least wonders and I would
say
six 50 of dads at least try it it's
probably a little more you would think
yeah because I would say 50 admit to
trying it yes you know what I mean
I talked about I talked to my boy Bass
about it like the next day
and you were looking like what's wrong
with you and I was like bro I know you
and I know when you're in this stage
you're going to try it he was like oh
I'm gonna try it I'm just not going to
Tweet about it you're not going to tell
the whole world that I am indulging so
people are definitely at least I'll say
trying it taking your Sip and just kind
of seeing how uh how it is so I also for
the record did not think it was weird at
all and I think most people didn't think
was weird but it was funny to say it was
weird yeah it was just the tweets were
amazing I feel like I went through so
many years I was I usually don't scroll
and like look at people's reply and all
that but I did and it was it was
hilarious is Jalen gonna follow you back
have you all had this conversation so
Jalen actually
um
he uh we talked me and Jayla talk
literally every day
um and I think he actually right before
that oh no right after he did it we were
on FaceTime and he was like yo check
Twitter and I saw that I'm like oh
he loved it yeah he he he
we've had several conversations about it
and it's just it's hilarious you know
what I think is so funny so obviously I
feel like you and Jalen are kind of
framed as you're like the Carefree fun
one who like loves to have a good time
and Jalen is more like
buttoned up I feel like Jalen is the
same way but we just don't see it is
that accurate yes okay just finessing
all you guys because Jalen is the most
immature
um Carefree just always playing guy that
you're probably one like that you'll
ever meet but once he like goes in front
of media does interviews you know cool
comic compose you know what I mean
doesn't doesn't praise himself Praises
his teammates if you ask him about
something that he did really well he's
gonna be like oh you know my guys put me
in a good position he's going to give
you all that BS but he like the real
Jalen and I think I tweeted it like like
a week or so ago I'm like y'all don't
know the real Jalen I think I did Jalen
and Michael yeah like y'all don't know
the real ones like we really talk every
day and it's we're playing literally
non-stop okay so give me an example like
what is something about the real Jalen
that we don't know or understand
um
first off he gets it from his parents
okay parents play all day especially his
mom Sandra's he plays all day but he
like
um
first off I could say
my Shannon my wife for you guys that
don't know obviously we're all cool and
she I think at one point she looked at
me she was like if your friend calls you
at 1am facetime's at 1am one more time
I'm done literally like we talked like I
don't want to say 24 times but we talk
all the time but
just ah man it's
tough to put like I will say you have
something in your head that you're like
not like nothing so I'm not going to
need you to tell the story yeah
we're both just very unfiltered
um
[Laughter]
yeah we're both just very unfiltered
what is making you laugh what is the
story
[Music]
how family friendly is this show that no
it is not at all I would mess around so
obviously like I got uh got the newborns
and I'm just I was messing with them and
I was changing I was changing I think
one of them Hendrix I think it was and
I'm gonna FaceTime with him he's crying
I'm and I just look at him like yo my
son's packing and that flip
you were like I'm proud I love the
camera he just started busting out
laughing like dog that's the type of
immature relationship that we have that
y'all don't see but like it's like
[Laughter]
a bunch of stuff like that I would say
the only thing that we have talked about
on this show a little crazier than that
was when I interviewed Ezra arasania and
I was talking about the craziest thing
you had to do to cut weight and he was
like
I uh had to bust a nut I said whoa what
happened
and I was like okay I did not want to go
into details or specifics but so just so
you feel better about your story this is
this is not an anomaly sound of number
two yeah so now now we know how you and
Jalen actually are but no it's genuinely
been such a joy watching you on the same
team because y'all are genuine friends
and I just think it shows in the press
conferences and obviously on the court
but you had this quote about Jalen you
said I think he kind of exceeded
everyone's expectations but his own what
did you mean by that
um
because if if you know like JB's Journey
right obviously like highly touted
coming out McDonald's on American you
know this and the other
had a very very successful college
career probably one of the best
um I'll say one of the probably the most
decorated college at you know basketball
athlete probably in the last like you
know 20 years 25 years
and with that he still wasn't projected
to be a first round pick he was
um I think most people projected him to
be
um
a solid piece coming off the bench you
know running a team you know running the
offense not doing anything too crazy not
having too much weight on his shoulders
um you know and then just you know if he
stuck with a team cool if not he was
going to be a journeyman he would have
been you just knew he was going to be in
the league right right but not like the
star the Solitude he's not what he what
he is now and I think like I said he
exceeded everyone's expectations but his
own and his family was because
no he knows the work he puts in you know
what I mean and me just knowing him at
Nova and knowing him now like I see the
work he puts in and
um one of my favorites you know
just little parts or stories or whatever
of him like was last year you know I
think it was the morning of you know
what free agency was about to start and
obviously at that point he you know
projected to get you know 100 million
dollars or whatever it is
and we're both at uh at Nova working out
in the morning and I forgot what I might
have got there like
7 30 or 8 and he's already in the in the
gym working out doing all that and this
is
what five six hours before you even
assigned a big you know one of the
biggest deals of his life families
taking care of kids taken care of and he
had that moment and you know a lot of
guys you know would be just chilling
just looking at the clock yeah and he's
in there not just working out but like
going hard doing all those things so
that that's my you know that's what I
you know I knew before because I you
know saw it but after I was like okay
and I told him that I was like yo I know
we play around but like this is you know
it's really dope to see I love that um
and that's just how he is so I'm not
surprised you know I'm not surprised
where he is I think
99.9 of the NBA were to R and uh that
point one is
um
Jalen
Rick his dad and
I won't even put myself in there yeah I
mean it probably just those two but he
just has always had that belief in
himself and his abilities I never
doubted that he's always had and there's
times like you know for like obviously
our games are different you know in my
game
you know a lot of energy
um physical you know so there's times
like at the games I'm just exhausted you
know especially like in college like
those time in college after a game you
know you played 30 you know 33 minutes
I'm sitting there tired bodies hurting
doing those I'm like I'm about to go get
something I'm like yo JB what you doing
he's like me and my dad about to you
know and nobody had the Pavilion in
right across the street is Davis
um where we practiced that and he was
like I'm about to go I'm about to go to
Davis me and my dad about to work out
and this is after a full full-blown game
wow I'm about to go work out so I'm just
like like this dude is this dude
are you serious yeah he really wants it
I'm saying they're like you know I'm
about to go I'm tired I'm about to go
eat a cheese steak he's I got work today
yeah he's about to go put work in it so
like that's that's him and obviously
Rick is a big part of that but
um you know now J you know JB's his own
man and and you get to see you know
that's that's that's him obviously he
was you know raised part of that way
with Rick but you know now that's that's
who he is I love that so I don't know if
you know this but I have actually known
Jalen since he was in like 10th or 11th
grade yeah because he didn't commit to
University of Illinois
but I was covering his recruiting and
what everybody would always say about
Jalen was just how hard of a worker that
he is and honestly I think in the league
hard work is a skill like a lot of
people know that they're talented and
they can just rely on having that talent
but when you're talented and you have
the work ethic that's what takes you to
that next level I think that he's always
understood that he can get there like he
can work on those things to become that
person so it's been such a good year for
him and I just think it's it's crazy in
so many ways he kind of manifested what
this moment was you know which is really
really nice so for you guys
being genuine best friends on a team how
do you deal with like I don't want to
say conflict but say you all don't agree
on something how do you navigate that
like we say what it is yeah if if
there's something that that I'm not
doing he like he'll sit there he can he
he can curse me out he's cursed me out
before and and it's been vice versa I
mean there were there was one time at
Nova he called me what uh we're in
practice and he called me with a elbow
and like people that know me know I I'm
I'm competitive I'm passionate
um but when I'm on the court I'm a I
have like a little bit of a crazy side
not crazy you know not too much
a little bit right and I feel like you
have to uh but he called me with an
elbow and I wish I could have to find a
practice film of it because he passed
the ball he ripped through caught me
passed the ball
and he I stopped he stopped we both just
looked at each other and we would know
like
I'ma you up like I'm not sure how
but somehow in this the duration of this
play you're going to get up yeah
so I think like
he got the ball back I let him drive
past me he wanted to go take a layup and
he and he and he knew it too so he
didn't really like he didn't even try to
go delay he just he just stopped at the
rim and I just boom just just leveled
him like he like in Davis like you have
the basketball probably like the court
like the the Hoops probably here he'll
look probably like eight feet of space
and then they're like the door you walk
in leveled them went through the door I
threw the ball at him and then
Coach Wright was just he he started
snapping obviously Chris Jenkins was on
the team he looked at me like oh you
good and I'm just like yo I'm cool yeah
now I'm good yeah
we can move on yeah coach is snapping
him like oh he comes with elbow like and
he he knew it was coming but like
you know he he did that and he knew it
and then you know after practice is over
like we cool I'll go get something
whatever so like we're comfortable with
each other in terms of uh challenging
each other
um if we don't
agree on something you know we figure it
out and see what the best option is
um and obviously I think that's
important to have in terms of
um you know when you guys on the same
team for sure okay who started the I
don't even know how to do it he's a
celebration he started it I'm like I
kind of know the origin but I don't
really know the origin
um and he hasn't really talked too much
of the origin of it so I can't really
you know blow up his spot but yeah he
does it and then you know me you know
when I do something I'm like you know
what it's like I did Michael's Michael's
I think I hit a three in Cleveland one
time and I did Michael's yeah
that's okay did that and then um I was
messing with him I was like I was like
JBC I did Kill he was like you didn't do
mine
uh you know I did something that I did
his okay I want to switch gears to you
obviously a lot of conversation about
you what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do obviously when I look up a lot
of stuff every single article says he is
expected to decline his pair option
which obviously makes sense because you
would become a restricted free agent get
the money that you want where are you at
with that are you declining that option
oh you're retiring
um yeah we'll probably decline that and
um do the free agency thing my my first
reagency was I was restricted and it was
oh that was like it was ass
um I'm not a very emotional person as my
wife is
um Can attest to and she would love me
to be even more emotional but I'm not um
but I think like my last version she was
like I I kind of actually cried a little
bit because I'm just like it took like
three weeks to get it done I'm like damn
like do people even like do I like do
people want me in the league like I'm
like it was just a lot and it was very
stressful so you know I don't think this
free agency would go that way
um
but yeah we do that but you know I love
New York
um I love the team I love the the
coaches that at the front office that we
have I think
um building in the right direction
um you know got young guys draft picks
do all the you know all those sort of
things so
um you know obviously that would be an
ideal place for me to just you know
resign there and do that obviously I
know it's a business they gotta want me
at a certain price and I got a one you
know with the same thing so I get this a
business but you know there is just
everything's perfect on the court off
the court you know with family being
close to home doing all those kind of
things so
um
you know fingers crossed that you know
yeah yeah
you know that you know I was like a deal
get done you know in the first day or
two yeah
um but yeah it's you know that that's
I would love for that to be home yeah so
to be clear like you want it to be the
New York Knicks you love it you feel do
you feel like you have found a home I
think so and I the reason why I mean at
least on the court
um
my I feel like my style of play
is kind of how the city is built in the
sense of
just blue collar hard-working you know
hard work hard worker
um
can do kind of whatever he needs to do
to just kind of be successful and to
help the team you know be successful and
I think that's kind of how New Yorker
that tough gritty
um style of a city
um other than that and I obviously like
I said off the court man just being so
close to home I think
my parents went to almost every home
game if not every home game my host
family lives in Jersey they were at
every game
um you know friends were there so it's
you know it just works yeah
I'll say that's a perfect situation and
I mean New York loves you you know
you're you're Heart of the City yeah uh
up there
um I do want to go back to something
that you just said how when you were
restricted free agent it was hard for
you that it was emotional for you just
because it's wild how time continues to
progress because the situation that
you're in now is going to be completely
different than the one that you were in
then in that moment like what was the
low point of that restricted free agency
period
um
I mean like I was
I think we finally got a deal done
probably
three weeks into free agency and it was
always like every day I was calling me
it's like yo do we have update do we
have something that was like this could
happen we're not sure you know there's
this there's this I thought it was
different you know options in the sense
but it wasn't anything you know to write
home about anything concrete and even
like the deal that I had
like I felt like at that point in my
career I was a good player someone I
could produce
um at a good level but I'm like I signed
a three-year contract with one year
guaranteed like
I felt like
I couldn't get a
fully get like this right and that's
obviously that's my that's not on my
ages I love Majors but like you know I
guess you know New Orleans Dave Griffin
didn't feel that way and it was that was
tough when I'm just like you know I you
know I fully embraced New Orleans when I
was there and I'm like I'm like damn
like
that that's all that it is you know just
when you're guaranteed if I if I get
hurt in this first year like I'm
hopefully a minimum the next year you
know what I mean so that was very
stressful that was a low point I'm just
like maybe I was like I guess you know
these guys don't want me how you know I
wanted it and that was very frustrating
yeah because I think
it's very easy
to maybe incorrectly at times like tie
your Worth to that yeah you're like does
does nobody want me and then it just
almost probably makes you second-guess
yourself and what you've done could you
have done more so how did you maybe get
out of feeling that way and especially
now I'm sure you feel very wanted
it was
it was more of a like that that next
year
um
and I loved playing with Willie Green
playing for for him and I had bi there
and and a lot of guys I was I was cool
like that that team I actually genuinely
love and I still talked a lot of those
guys now but I really was coming into
the mentality of
just like you like not to my
teammates I thought it coaches because
you know first with Coach green but you
know to the front office to to the city
it was like like I'm a show like uh you
know I'm worth more than this I'm gonna
go and I'm gonna handle my business I'm
a I'm gonna be a leader I'm gonna do
everything I'm supposed to do and then
you know I knew my contract you know was
very tradable and I knew I most likely
would get traded and it was like I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna hoop I'm gonna
bust my ass and I'm uh
go somewhere else and then y'all gonna
be sitting there like damn we let him
leave again that was what I was going in
for and I think you know I accomplished
that I I think you did too so when
you're going on to the court that's
something you're like I want to prove
who I am and what you're missing out on
that something you're thinking about for
sure
um
because that was just like that that
chip on my shoulder for for me it's like
you know
I signed that you know I signed that
deal and I like I just I wasn't happy I
signed it just you know to to do it but
I was like
should I just sit there and play for
this qualifying offer like that was like
what I was thinking and just try to do
free agency next year understood getting
just go
Um so it was I signed it I did you know
me and my my wife and I did dinner
and I just
you know it just wasn't like a
celebration it was just kind of like
okay did something you know we we're
good for another year yeah yeah and
that's why I think for you when you talk
because I've seen you talk a lot about
wanting a home I think it's just that
stability and like feeling like you're
at the place you're supposed to be and
everybody else feels like you're
supposed to be there so I mean it when I
say I'm genuinely happy that you had
this season and I think you really
showed everyone who you are and what you
could do and I don't I don't think
you'll be in that position again so I I
am truly truly happy for you like I said
I know New York has embraced you being
in the city though have you seen what
people mean when they say everything's
just more important there the spotlight
is brighter It's a Jungle when you are
an athlete playing in New York City do
you feel that way uh yeah uh I see it I
feel it and I think
I'll say I was a little bit more ready
for it than
most just because I was in LA yeah and
LA
the media is not as bad in LA but the
fan base like boy they turn on you quick
there's three really tough markets to be
in in terms of fans yeah and it's New
York LA and Philly yes it really might
be the worst oh I mean if you lose
driver need to be right there get out
get out quick like and obviously I
played at Nova we're out right outside
of Philly so we obviously we had some
Philly support and all that and and it
was great but there's been time there
was games we was getting booed off our
home court you know Philly fans are
ruthless and I think that's part of the
reason why you you know you always
always also love them because they they
show you what it is yeah um so I feel
like I was ready for it a little bit
um
but for me it's like I never really
tried to
let that dictate you know how I play or
or my mood just because at the end of
the day no matter what anybody says no
matter what the media says no matter
what you know any of those you know
anybody says any fans Twitter or
whatever it is like I'm my hardest
critic like I go home like
you're gonna my wife hates it because
obviously NBA season
you know if you don't even make the
playoffs 82 games and
when I lose
um I'm shot for a day day and a half and
really if I and if I'm I feel like I
caught starting the game I feel like
you know there was one game I think
for an example was in there was two a
couple games in Portland like there was
one where I think we played Denver I
want to say
and we got us you know we had a steal
and I went I had a layup and I someone
passed me the ball and I just I I
bobbled it on a fast break and then I
tried to get it and I slipped but we
turn the ball over I think we end up
losing and like I was I was shot for and
it was like two or three day break into
the next game she felt like it was on
yeah I felt like I was frustrated
because we obviously we lost I was
frustrated but like I let my my guys
down and I I didn't I didn't really talk
to my wife even
um you know for for two three games for
the next next game and some of the
teammates was like yo Jay all right like
you good how are you I'm like I'm I'm
good when we play again yeah like not
like last game was terrible there was
one game in Dallas I was I was like oh
for nine and we get we got we lost
I think Luca before the direct you know
trade with Spencer like Luca hit a
couple big like a victory at the end
Spencer had a couple big three at the
end we lost I didn't I didn't make a
field goal I was terrible shot terrible
from the free throw line I was I was
smoked for two games two days two years
two three days yeah into the next game
so I'm not saying it is or isn't but
when you get into those modes do you
feel like it's healthy for you or do you
wish you could get out of them okay I I
wish I could get out of them and and
it's tough because I I can't and
Alex has one thing I was really excited
about with kids because they don't care
if you have a bad game a good game they
don't care so now it's like hopefully
um I can leave a lot of that at the door
when I come home yeah
um and you know you see the little
smiling faces chunky cheeks and all that
you know over that kind of you know has
all that frustration and stress kind of
just you know good you know Fall by the
wayside so that's something I'm very
looking forward to but
um
you know I gotta try to find that
balance of
you know letting that go and you know
moving on not just in terms of
basketball but just in terms of Life
yeah and also knowing what parts of that
actually make you go right because
there's some of that that it makes you
good
at your job for sure you know but also
learning okay if I let some parts of
that go how else would it make me good
you know so but I feel like that is
probably a journey for everyone and
every job is this figure
you know my wife might love me a little
more because I'm not I'm not starting
Petty arguments you know we I lose I
play terrible she asked me what what I
want to eat I'll snap
something she's like well damn like I'm
not the reason why you missed three
threes today you know what I mean so
um you know maybe she'll love me a
little more uh if I can fix that but
yeah like I said you gotta have part of
it yeah but you can't
you can't do that every game but you
can't have it to that extent all the
time yeah it can't consume you exactly
okay so I want to talk your playoff
series uh against the Heat a little bit
if somebody said to you how and why did
you lose to the heat what would your
answer be
um
we didn't make shots but I think I think
I mean
look at how the Heat played against
the Bucks look how they played against
Boston all right they were what they
were the worst offensive team in the
league and during the season they
started around yeah I mean that that
shows you the regular season don't mean
nothing totally because they just they
were kicking it they were you know
obviously a little hurt you know they
was kind of kid and they were y'all
trying to get that AC yeah when it was
time to go they was on go yeah but like
like my Milwaukee had like number one
defense in the league and they were out
there scoring
120 130 points a game I think they
in our playoff game
the most they scored was maybe like 108
like we were we were holding them to you
know low hundreds
um and it was possession games and then
some of them were just we didn't make
shots yeah you know what I mean and it's
not just you know myself I put myself
over the top of that on myself
um even like Jalen who's our our guy
who's our
um our dude there were some games where
he was like oh for seven for three you
know what I mean it was game with Julius
was like oh five yeah yeah so things
weren't falling and I think
sometimes obviously it's frustrating you
know confidence can you know
NBA yes there's you know it goes up and
down by the game yeah um I just think it
was what was that coming if you hold a
team to
you know 39 from the field
shooting uh you know scoring 104 points
um if you ask any NBA coach would you
take that and they'll say yes absolutely
yeah every day of the week and it just
so happened that you know we held them
to 40 from from issue you know shooting
from the field and 104 points and we
just ended up shooting 38.
sometime you know what I mean so it's
you know I think that was the biggest
thing in obviously that is frustrating
and it's tough though to swallow because
you feel like you could have
beat them you feel like you could have
moved on but you know you got to give
them credits bow made a great Injustice
so good
um they got guys that's won
championships with with Kayla with with
Kyle Lowry over there I said Kayla K
LOVE Kyle Lowry
um and then you got hungry dudes uh with
Caleb and Gabe Vincent Max struse
obviously Jimmy's Jimmy
um Caleb going crazy yeah bam playing
well Duncan you know what was out of
rotation obviously Tyler got hurt he
came in and he's been playing great for
them yeah so you got to just tip your
head you know sometimes you just gotta
tip your hat to the other other team and
say you know what
you know
we think we could have beat you I think
Milwaukee think they could have beat
them I think Boston think they could
have beat them and you know
if you were supposed to you would have
yeah we got to tip our hat to him and
say we know we we might have gave that
series up just with our lack of you know
shot making but you gotta get on the
credit there they've been they've been
hooping and you know that's a a tough uh
tough team
um and you know we're still the best I'm
not saying this to you but somebody
somebody said to me once they're like
saying you should have made more shots
it's just another way of saying you lost
and I was like damn that's true exactly
yeah and that's how it is I mean you see
you know the couple games that we won we
we made shots yeah I agree and we had
open like they they gave us open shots
you know what I mean so and we just we
just didn't make them so
you know
that's the thing
what we just talked about we got to try
to let it go no for sure and we won't
use it as motivation use that as full
for this off season but
um tip our hats to them and you know
go watch them in the finals
unfortunately
well the thing about the Knicks
obviously from the startup season to
what actually happened by the end of the
season the team exceeded expectations
yeah the city was so behind everything
even just honestly being in the playoffs
I think was a win for everybody in New
York there's obviously been a lot of
conversation about what does failure
mean in the league and what does success
mean in the league yeah so to you when
you look at what happened with you all
which one do you label it as
I think it was a success
um
if you sit there and judge a season by
if you win a championship or not like
that's just idiotic to me just because
let's be real there's 30 NBA teams
going into a season
there's five maybe six contenders that
teams are you like you know what they
can make a final round yeah and
there's
you know probably on the other side
there's probably six out of like
yeah can't wait for that draft pick baby
and then you have guys exactly and then
you have guys that are teams that are in
the middle that that are trying to
figure it out and
um so for for me to put
uh to labor our our season as a failure
or success based on a championship I
think that's unfair you know what I mean
there was before you know before I got
there you know just watching on the
outside looking in you know
people were killing them they might not
make the playoffs they lost nine in a
row at one point they did that and the
other so you know y'all go from this
team's the worst team in the league
losing nine in a row to them winning
nine in a row just like oh my God we can
make the second round of playoffs and
all that like you know I think it's
unfair to you know if you would like
that but
I think that's the logic then only one
team and that that can't be how it goes
exactly yeah
um I mean I I think San Antonio
they they were successful I think they
they got they they were very successful
and they and they were a terror they
were one of the worst teams in the
league and they were very successful
yeah so you can't view it like you know
you just can't view it like that and if
you do you know that's your prerogative
but
um
you know I think I think we
we did what we were supposed to do
um even exceeded to expectations and
we're bringing that into
you know next season
so we say that next season is a success
uh before you even got to the team uh
Tibbs called you the best rebounding
guard in the league are you for sure I
mean like if
Russ is up there obviously Luke is up
there you know what I mean but I think I
am just in terms of
Lucas what six eight you know what I
mean
Russ
is what six five and athletic I'm like
six four six five I'm not that athletic
you're like I'm getting it done yeah I'm
I'm here for a good time you know what I
mean
um so I think I am just in terms of
just going pursuing rebounds you know in
my zone out my zone
um so I think I am and that's one of the
um
I think that's one of those things in my
game that I use that especially you know
defense rebounds to push the pace and
get try to get easy bucks on the
offensive end and then on the offensive
end try to get extra possessions
um for my guys and I think
especially playing in Portland with Aunt
and Dame like
you know getting getting off into
rebound getting them that's probably
what time we get them the most open yeah
they are so
um it was the opportunity to get them in
a rhythm get them open shots get them
good looks with it I'll have to sit
there and work for everything you had
said to Mitchell Robinson once I don't
want to mess up the quote you said
you get the regular rebounds I'll get
the rebounds the breakdowns what do you
mean by that
like for me it's
you play the first three quarters cool
fourth quarter especially that last four
minutes that's that's when you that's
that's when you went that's winning time
you know what I mean so for me
especially on the offensive end like you
watch games and obviously you're a
basketball mine you're not one of them
just a casual fan it's like oh my God so
you're actually watch and dissect you
know what actually happens but you know
how many times has there been offering
to rebound you you force the team to a
tough
tough shot at the end of a shot clock
and they get an offensive rebound the
last three minutes of the game hit a
three and it's like that's this
game dagger you thought of game one
against uh against the Heat we we did we
did that exact same thing we came down
rebound Kyle Lowry popped it out hit
game um they got Exposition gave Vincent
um hit hit a three where he tried to
draw a foul he didn't they didn't get
the foul call but he drained the three
that went from a three-point game I
think it was to a six-point game at four
minutes to go and it was and it was it
was over at that point so for me I want
to make those plays I want to be the guy
to go against offensive Rebound in a one
possession game get it get us open shot
get us extra possession do those kind of
things that's what I want that's what I
live for that's how I play yeah so
that's kind of what I mean
um by that and I think I've done that on
a lot of occasions and
um that's just kind of like the
mentality that I have especially in the
fourth quarter
we clear not really debatable that you
are one of the best coast to coast
attackers
um in the league something I think is
interesting though when I watch you
obviously you kind of get a lot of texts
[Music]
and
my wife let me know about
it and then I'm I'm saying that there is
it feels like who you are when you're
playing a basketball at least from what
I know of you is like very different
from who you are in real life for sure
so are you almost like turning on like a
like a Beyonce Sasha Fierce alter sort
of ego when you go out there
like because
once I go out there the competitiveness
starts you know what I mean and it's
practice is cool warm-ups are cool all
that stuff once I check into the game
like you see like and even like you'll
see me you know joke around you know
pre-game doing all this stuff sometimes
I'm on the bench I'll be joking around
but once I'm on that Court once I'm
playing there's no games you know
sometimes if we're about 20 or something
like that then we're playing games a
little bit but once you're in it you're
uncompetitive
um on 100 expect and then you know if I
feel like there's
um a discrepancy whether it's fouls or I
feel like I got fouled or or something I
didn't get a call I'm snapping like I'm
like dog like like you know
[Laughter]
and most of the Reps I I always say
what's up to him before the game a lot
of times I'll unless I'm just heated
after a game I always you know tell them
like you know thank you appreciate it
yeah
you know they have the hardest job like
no matter what they're gonna have you
know one one team extremely pissed at
them they're gonna have one fan base
extremely mad at them yeah they're gonna
you know be labeled you know cheaters or
you know sear extenders or this and the
other so they they got probably the
worst job and you know it takes a lot uh
to be a ref so I gotta commend that like
that you know that they have the
toughest job
and they have a tough job because they
have like me that when they
think they they get a foul get fouled
and don't sit there and snap at them
then a lot of times when I look at the
replay I'm like and then I sit there and
be like yo Curtis that's my fault yeah
you know Tony said Tony and I go I was
out of pocket you know what I mean yeah
they have a hard job but I mean that's
why you have a burner just kidding
um I want to rewind a little bit because
I don't know if you remember this I feel
like you have a good memory but back
when I was at SNY I was covering a lot
of the Villanova games like I had
interviewed you and Jalen and Dante at
the Garden coincidentally because I
think it was it was the tournament yeah
the odd one and it was just so clear how
close everyone was yeah how happy
everyone was
did you get a lot of Joy just being a
Villanova oh my God it was you know some
of the best times of My Life
um you know I'm extremely close with
what all those guys
um you know those guys I'm in the league
that Nova guys I'm trying to get you
know get the NY you like the Tweet about
Dante uh are you trying uh remember me
that's my guy you know what I mean I was
talking to him the other day but uh the
Tweet by the way said that Dante could
be the shooting that the Knicks need so
that's that's what's on Josh's mind
everyone but not yet like those are my
guys because
uh as you know it just uh an athlete and
when you're in those situations
especially when you go you know you go
on the road you know it's just the guys
in the locker room you know what I mean
it's just just your boys so we had that
culture of High character guys and we
were all
extremely close we all actually
genuinely liked each other so you know
those those four years that I had there
were amazing I talked to all those guys
you know to this day
um
and it was you know obviously it helped
when you win and you're being successful
obviously as a team and a program
individually but
um you know those are my brothers and I
hope
um you know we can share the court uh
you know uh you know for for a long time
and hopefully in the same uniform
but uh you know I love those guys so you
obviously decided to return to Villanova
your senior year when you made that
decision was it an all-smiles decision
or were you
kind of upset that you weren't going to
be going to the league and kind of
changing your life
um
it was a little both a little both I was
extremely excited to go back to Nova you
know try to compete for another
championship
um it's a fruit fly oh my God no it
didn't me too yeah I I haven't I haven't
worked you know I just had someone spray
eye you know it's working no one on
me because my I have fruit flies on my
outside
um but uh it was
I was looking forward to it because I
knew we had a chance to win I like the
guys there I had the ability to get my
diploma to something I really wanted
um obviously you know
I wish I was going to leave making
millions doing all that yeah but
everyone has their own path and mine was
going back to Nova and taking it that
way and
um I'm at a tough tough loss and uh
against Wisconsin
you know if you talk to Jalen you know
he says I should have passed him the
ball I think it still leads me up today
he told everyone I should have passed
him the ball at the end of that
possession so now you know game six of
the Ace of conference semifinals I could
say he should have passed me the ball
with 10 seconds left I was open
um but but uh but I I had fun and it was
it was a blast being able to go back for
my last year with with my Bros and you
know just at least be a kid again for
another year and I think I think both of
us and everyone that's graduated college
or you know older in their 20s or 30s
they're like yeah I wish I could go back
yeah
out of it I would you know I'm happy I
didn't cheat myself that one more year
yeah it's like I definitely don't want
to have to turn in assignments by
midnight but I would love to be on the
campus exactly
and so before Nova I just want to paint
this scene because I don't know if
basketball fans always understand what
it's like being in high school if you're
like an elite player especially where
you're at the elite like talented
basketball players in the DC area yeah
would go to these schools that were
super Elite normally predominantly very
white schools for you on a scale of one
to ten like how much of a culture shock
was that to you to go to that school as
opposed to whatever was in your area
I want to do like the The Annoying
Thing like 1 to 10 or 20 right you're
like but 20. yeah 20 like I hate people
that do that but it was like that yeah
um but not it was it was a complete
culture shot because obviously going to
public school you know my whole life
um and then going to uh a school and it
wasn't like you know in in DC you have
Gonzaga the math that those are the two
like basketball powerhouses at least
they were at that you know during that
time Montrose Christian
um you had those
and I went to see what Friends School
nobody knows what the hell Subway
school is a junior ivy league type
school like kids there that go to you
know Harvard Yale Brown Tufts like those
really successful prestigious academic
schools so
I went there for basketball and had no
idea what I walked into yeah obviously
um like I said predominantly white
um and it was just it was a culture
shock for me and I wasn't fully ready
for it I I honestly kind of hated it at
the time you know part of it because
um you know I was just you know just a
regular kid family didn't have money or
you know like that and you know like
hearing the conversations of others and
you're like I don't relate to this at
all yeah there was a time like my you
know a couple of you know friends I was
there and they were like yo and like
they could leave campus for lunch I was
like oh this will make them first
I'm like why y'all leaving cabins we got
a whole little nice spread right here
that's free there's nothing else you
need yeah
um we had a it was called the fox den
which was like a little coffee shop and
all that they was out there Brewing
cappuccinos and all that I'm like it was
amazing that's crazy
um yeah exactly
um because I was like yo about to you
know we want to go to you know let's
walk like walk down to Chipotle for
lunch I'm like hey bro I don't got seven
dollars for Chipotle you know what I
mean I I barely had you know several
dollars to put on this Smart Trip you
know my parents give me five dollars for
the smart chip you know which was the uh
the um the bus the busting so
um you know they give me five ten
dollars I'll sit there try to you know
I'll make my way
to you know we had a what where was it
it was Tinley town so I'll take the bus
get to Tinley town and now take another
bus from Tinley town to Sidwell so I was
you know I wouldn't give them ten
dollars the first ride I'd be like ah
like it'd be like I'm like oh man I
don't got no money I'll get there I'll
go to like CVS I'll get like a couple
you know a couple like 99 cent snacks
and now I have like 750 I'll put on my
Smart Trip so I got some snacks yeah oh
but I'm like yeah bro I barely got a
bread to get get on the bus and y'all
and I'm like I I can't right and you're
like and y'all want a burrito boy yeah
exactly and we're you know five minutes
down from Georgetown you know all these
kids are driving
they go you know they want to go to
Georgetown or the shop or walk around
all that I'm like bro I don't want to go
to Georgetown I can't buy anything at
Georgetown why do I want to go there
like for me they didn't I don't no one
looked at me like that but like for me
it was embarrassing come like I I can't
like I can't afford like this isn't in
my class this isn't in my league like I
don't want to do this so part of it
hated that time cause I'm like
I'm not in this
you know world and it wasn't even like
about basketball and
um that was my first year and then I
struggled academically and and they
asked me not to come back and that was
frustrating for me too because I was
trying I was trying my best as you know
public school you know sometimes you
just turn assignment in and you're
getting and you'll get it yeah
you know you had to explicate poems I
don't even know what escalated me you
know I mean they were saying they're
yeah this this word started with a
capital capital letter that means that
writer really you know wanted to
emphasize you know the this word and
that I'm just like huh yeah I'm like and
I'm like maybe he just started this
sentence I mean maybe something you know
what I mean like just you know that's
how it goes I'm like it was just
something that was just so beyond you
know what I was ready for and
um you know some parents students really
rallied behind me to get me readmitted
and they started a petition yeah sorry
petition and got me remitted because
they felt like Sidwell didn't put the
necessary resources that I needed to be
successful because they were very like
this is the bar if you're at the bar by
the bar cool if you below the bar that's
not our job to catch all up to speed to
the bar so if you're below the bar
you can go to bullets or one of the
mother what a mother school or something
Georgetown prep no not over here but
honestly
they're coming she talks about she's
like education and she's like children
teens right young adults know when
people do not believe in them yes and
that bleeds into what they can do and
I'm sure there was like something in the
back of your head that was like I know
like I don't really have any Advocates
here and that in turn probably made you
not go as hard as maybe you would have
it's just one of the teachers really
believed in you yeah you know yeah and
and I think the the cool thing about it
was there was
at least to start they were the couple
teachers that were like
like why is this kid here why this kid
in this class why is he at the school I
I'm not gonna put it there's a couple
that come to mind but I don't want to
put their names out there but they're
but it was cool for me because they got
to just know me not in terms of being a
student just as a kid and you know some
of those teachers after that first year
when I got us not to come back
they went and rallied behind me a guy in
my corner and it was
um that was something that was really
dope for me and and at that point it was
my parents you know super dope and they
they let me decide if I wanted to go
back or if I wanted to go to like
Montrose or whatever and
I was like I can go to Montrose you know
stuvettes there he has connections I can
you know Frankie can go up office can go
up he's in there saying I could
potentially be at McDonald's
All-American if I go there and then
stand to other but I'm like all that
sounds cool
like am I do I really want to leave all
the people that just fought for me right
to be readmitted do I want to you know
some of these teachers that that said
that they will help me or tutor me after
hours they do other things I want to
leave that situation no I don't want to
do that situation some of these people
right behind me help me get the parents
you know donated help me get laptops and
stuff like that so I'm like I can't lead
that situation and it wasn't even about
basketball so like my high school years
like it wasn't even about basketball it
was just about you know growing growing
as a person if you're asking my wife
she's like I'm totally different you
know now or at the end than I was you
know when I got into Sidwell and
that's the part was like part of me was
embarrassing and I hate it
um it sometimes at the time but now
looking back oh my God I I love it and
and it did so much to help me get to
where I am now yeah and there was also
I'm sure probably some element of
wanting to just kind of finish what you
started you know and wondering maybe
what you would think about yourself if
you like exactly and it was cool because
my uh
I was able to finish what I started and
my dad kept I think he still has a
letter the original letter that they
sent sent us in the mail basically
saying you know you think you know ask
your kid not to come back think he can
be better at a different different you
know institution than other and he kept
that and I think he still has it to the
day and it's and that's like some of the
cool things that you know you know all
my friends are from from that time my
host family my host brother who's lives
in Miami he's actually coming coming
tonight you know to hang out and hang
out Matt yeah Matt exactly you know all
those guys my girlfriend or my wife now
um went to city with me all during my
high school years and because I was in
that situation and it's you know I I owe
a lot of what I am in my life to sit
well and the people there that that put
me in this position and that was like
the coolest thing because this it wasn't
even about basketball basketball was
cool I was recruited decently and all
that like
I'll I'll take you know I'll go back to
Sidwell any day and and relive those
days of embarrassment but also just fun
laughter love and you know a home yeah I
mean you got to get that letter from
your dad and like frame it because it's
just it's such a testament to like
you aren't what anyone says you are you
know like you can decide who you want to
be and show up on all those days so I
love that um I'm gonna go like 15 more
minutes we are keeping you along I hope
that's okay I got nothing to do today
you keep me away from changing diapers
and doing all that stuff
uh you talked about your parents you had
a quote that I thought was so good and I
want you to explain you said I think my
parents loved who they raised I think
they hated how they had to do it what do
you mean by that
um
I think
you know obviously as a parent you
always want your kid to grow up better
than you did right you want to put them
in good position to succeed and I think
I missed it
um
obviously they wanted the best for me
they wanted you know to me to have all
the nicest things you know the the best
hooping gear the best you know nice
clothes and all that especially when I
got to Sidwell
um
you know they they wanted that and you
know they weren't able to give me it you
know there was times when my mom
um you know
I was I want we weren't
you know there was people that were way
worse way worse off in terms of
financially and stuff like that so
obviously I always try to you know be
respectful of what I was like I don't
want to make something like yeah we got
out the streets you know what I mean
because there were people that really
had to do that but it was you know at
that time it was frustrating it was
times where you know obviously parents
couldn't go to games because I had to
work or
um you know Mom would you know try to
eat at at work you know we're at the
country club that she worked at because
you know we were you know didn't have
whatever so I think that was frustrating
with them I think you know my dad did it
you know a lot you know a good job in
terms of being at my games and I feel
like my mom wanted to be at more of my
games and stuff like that but obviously
she couldn't because she had to work she
had to help provide and put food on the
table and Etc so
um and I think that would probably
heightened a little bit when I got to
Sidwell because
you got all these people to have you
know nice cars you have people that
um
know politicians kids people that are
well off have nice clothes nice you know
stuff stuff that you know that they just
leave lying around you know in public
school and all that like you're saying
they're like you're fighting for that
for
um so I think it was that but I think
they were still able to instill the
principles that they wanted to and I
think it was a little bit harder for
them to do some of those things and now
being older obviously
um
I respect them even more than I did at
that point because I get to see it from
a different perspective now and so
that's kind of what I meant for that I I
feel like they wish they could have gave
me everything that I wanted as a kid and
I couldn't but I think now being the
person I am being the the man the
husband the Father the
um
not even a basketball player just the
person I think they're happy about I
think my and I know my dad's probably
gonna watch his interview and uh I'm
sure he'll probably be happy with most
of the stuff I'm saying but maybe not
the cuss word so my bad my bad dad
um yeah but um
yeah that's that's kind of what I meant
by that and I you know I hope I
um I hope they feel the same way and I
hope I've made them
um proud and it's their time to relax
kick their feet up enjoy life not have
to worry about anything financially or
anything like that you know what I mean
like I I have them and
um you know it's time for them just to
kind of
do whatever the hell they want to do
have you been able to have that
conversation with your parents or your
dad specifically
about
you being okay like that even though you
maybe didn't have everything you wanted
like you were okay you were loved you
were happy have you been able to tell
your parents that it was okay
um
no I never I don't think I ever have and
I think now thinking of it I definitely
should
um
because obviously
you know growing up you know those are
your parents you know sometimes this to
them sometimes you don't you know
especially like as a kid growing up as a
boy especially like you don't do all the
emotional you don't do that like
it's kind of like the man up kind of
thing keep it moving
and I never
you know
I don't feel like I never really got
that vulnerable with them and let them
know that and I feel like that's
something that
um
I think I'm gonna have that conversation
with them at some point I'm not sure
when
um I'm trying to work on myself in terms
of being more emotional being more
vulnerable realizing that
you know even you know obviously I'm a
man and you have to quote unquote man up
type thing like but no one knows what
that means like 100 I'm a I'm a person
who has feelings has emotion to I
shouldn't be scared afraid to to show
those things and it's not weak to show
them exactly and um
I'm you know consistently trying to
you know
understand that and learn that and I
think I'm doing a better job than I was
um I think you know having my kids I'm
able to see it a little bit better from
that perspective so
um that's a conversation that that I
hope to have with them soon and
um don't do like the
too cool for it or too quote unquote
manly or whatever you know hopefully I
have that you know when I have that
conversation I allow myself to be
emotional and to be vulnerable and cry
if I want to because who's going to tell
me not to absolutely you know what I
mean so
um I'm happy you brought that up because
that's definitely something that I'm
gonna have to do good I hope so and I
mean I don't I don't want to know the
ins and outs of the conversation because
that's obviously incredibly personal I'm
just asking you this because you said
your dad is going to watch this so what
is just the one thing you would want
your parents to always know
um
I would say
obviously always have like the oh I love
them type thing that's very cliche but
um
extremely happy with
how they raised me the decisions that
they've made
um
and there was a time
when I went back to said well when I got
when I got readmitted and I and you know
the Hillman's Matt and and his parents
they uh let me live with you know they
were saying you know he can live with us
you know he has classes with Matt he can
get study him study habits from him time
management
um kind of can have his own space
because at that point we were in a
two-bedroom apartment with like six
people you know I had the five you know
my family my five people my dad
um took in one of my uh brother's
friends who was
struggling at that time
and to let them know like
you know
they were never forgotten they were
never a second fiddle there were never
you know put on the back burner
for you know anyone
um I think that's the biggest thing and
I think that was something that they
were
they didn't really talk to me about but
I feel like that's something that was in
their mind not now but initially it was
like
you know he goes lived with another
family he's you know he he's away from
us for
six days out the week you know come you
know five days school days and then
obviously on the weekends you know you
don't want to be at home
friends you want to do all that so I
think they were kind of nervous that
I would
I don't want to say forget
that aspect of like how I was raised and
that but
um I think they were just fearful of
like the outcome and how we could you
know how it could be and
um
you know want them to know that that was
never that was never the case and you
know it never is the case never was a
case and that
um
everything that they did for me was
might not have seen like I appreciate it
at the time but looking back at it man
it was
it was amazing and they're just two
incredibly strong people who you know
I'm so happy that they're my parents I'm
so proud of them I'm so happy with
um the way they raised me because it
made me who I am and they put
um they instilled those values in me
that I'm gonna take you know until I'm
gone that I'm gonna try to understand my
kids and I wish I could be half
the man have the parent that my dad is
half the parent that my mom is
um and I feel like if I'm half of that I
feel like my kids would be in a good
situation
um that's beautiful so
um there's that I'm trying not to get
too emotional because if I do I'll
probably start crying on here but um no
it's okay that's beautiful yeah that's
something that I definitely want them to
to know and uh
if I go make my dad cry so high cry
before me no that's so beautiful I hope
I hope you do get to have that that
conversation with them you know I think
that when there are people who we know
for a fact love us and people that we
know they know we love them we feel like
we don't have to verbalize it no but
that's one thing I'm trying to work on
too is just like if we know it let's
talk about it you know because it's just
sometimes hard to do it so I I totally
get it yeah it sounds hard to do it and
especially
I feel like everyone when you know when
that person or who somebody is gone out
their life and you know they pass away
you know you're always looking back
saying I wish I would have said this I
wish I would have done that and I think
right now I'm like I wish I had I should
have had some of these conversations
before so now it's like I want to have
these conversations now so I don't so
they know you know what you know when
it's all said and done and they're and
it's time for them to move on
um
that they know what they meant to me
they know how
nothing was unsafe nothing was unsaid
and I think that's the biggest thing not
just for parents but
friends and and
um you know especially for guys you know
it's not a masculinity thing it's not
being too tough for it's just something
that
you know we can't be scared to be
vulnerable we can't be scared to be
hurting we can't be scared to be doing
all those kind of things that I want to
go into some
and that's something that I'm you know
every day I'm trying to teach myself and
get better at I love that give it up for
parents
okay uh the last five minutes
um on the subject of guidance
um in the league who has been your best
vet
oh
um
that's tough I would say
Larry Nance helped and obviously he's
only a couple years yeah Larry was
definitely big being that Kyle Lowry
um what was big
um
who else
only had Dane for half no a year I guess
but he he been he's been great and then
there's guys that's that I didn't never
even played with like CJ McCollum who
who's helped me with certain things and
um you know so I probably would say
those guys
um
yeah yeah you've played with a lot of
guys that are either just like
incredibly popular or just disgust a lot
or just really relevant whether that's
LeBron Dame Zion so many people which of
the guys you've played with do you feel
like is kind of the most misunderstood
by people that don't know them Dame
and he's
misunderstood because
you know
everyone we're in that we're in a a
culture where it's like you gotta win a
championship you have to win a ring you
have to do all that so it's like kind of
like with the the season the very
success so it was going to tell me his
his season or his career his career yeah
wasn't a success because they didn't
want to ring no he he's someone who is
extremely loyal he's someone who
um obviously came from you know Oakland
underrated at Weber State
um and then got drafted there and he
really embraced being in Portland and
Portland embraced him and me being
important for only a year I I understand
why he's so loyal because that fan base
is amazing like they they truly show you
love there was time we were getting our
ass up by 40 and they're still there at
the end of the game and I'm sitting
there looking like yo why are here
I would have been left if I didn't if I
wasn't put if I didn't have this jersey
or if I would you know if I didn't have
this jumpsuit and on this bench I would
be gone
um so people don't understand that but
like he's had such an amazing career all
the time leading scorer for you know for
the Blazers I don't know how many
All-Star how many time
um all NBA team and people just sit
there and like oh he's he's too Laurel
he has to go he has to win a ring he has
to do all this and that's something
that's
to me it's just stupid I know he wants
to win
but he wants to win the right way and he
he loves Portland and I'm not saying he
he would never leave Portland because I
don't know that that's up to Dame and
I'm not sure you know how that is but I
think he's misunderstood because people
see that loyalty and they don't
understand it but at the end of the day
he's the only one that has to walk in
his shoes yeah and as long as he
understands it and he's happy with it
and he and he loves it
what were we to say for sure you know
yeah I mean I think Dame for sure
probably has been misunderstood
misunderstood by media members as well
is he a superstar I think there's few
Superstars I think there are a few
Superstars but one thing about Dame I
love Dame Dame is the nicest person like
literally one of my favorite NBA players
for sure but I think he has been
misunderstood and going back to what
you're saying I don't even know if it's
that
he wants to win the right way I just
think he wants to win the way that feels
good to him you know what I mean yes
I'll say that yeah it's like he wants to
do it how Dame wants to exactly the
right way to him and that right way is
interpreted in his own way absolutely
and I think that's like how we have to
talk about what success and failure is
it's like what a success to you as an
individual exactly and nobody and
including me has a say in whatever that
is you know and I think it takes like a
very specific kind of person to be so
self-aware and so sure of who you are
yeah that you're gonna do the thing that
you want to do because you feel good
about it you know and I think
that's something that I learned when I
got to the league because like when I
got in I'm like all I want to do is win
all I want to do is win you know I want
to leave I want to retire with at least
a ring and I still do and that's what I
fight for and that's what I play the
game for
but my mindset changed in terms of
you know how I view that in My Career
Success my career is not you know not a
success just because I win a ring if I
don't run a ring it's not a fairy like
um I'm a kid that didn't grow up with
much that you know I'm going to be able
to put my family in a better position
than I did and to me that's a success to
me being able to
um you know have my kids in private
school and you know have a couple houses
and you know have a summer house
somewhere
exactly like put my kids in a good
position hopefully put their kids kids
and go to take care of my family doing
like that's success of me and
that was success to me before I got in
the league even the first couple years I
got when I was in the league that wasn't
what success was for me but now
um trying to see if I'm a different side
you know I'm over like yeah other Dad
I've been down for three questions
yeah but like yeah you know if if Mike
you know if my kids and they're like we
want you to call it quits
and we want you to hear more I'm calling
it quits I'm being here more and that's
whether that's four years down the line
or eight years down the line like when
they feel like I they're not getting me
as a dad it's time for me to hang it up
absolutely and when I hang it up I'll
still view my career as a success you
know even if I didn't win a ring right
because it's what is success because
success to me okay I love that
um I can't let you go without asking you
something I have wondered for what's up
an incredibly long time
when you were traded from the Lakers you
posted a selfie smiling
was that related to the trade from the
Lakers
it was and it was
smiling through the pain
because I was I was sick I did not want
to leave I was I posted that as like a
false front of like oh yeah I'm excited
to go into one of the time like not like
I got to LA and my biggest thing is I
always wanted to be in the league and be
with you know at least one team for a
long time I wanted a place to be to to
have
um as home and
you know that that that was a bummer for
me to to get traded obviously it was a
you know traded you know you traded for
a guy like A.D like there's no
you know I didn't feel like it was
disrespected or something it's not like
yeah I didn't I didn't get traded for a
copy machine or like some cash or
something like that like I got traded
for you know a top five playing in the
league at that point but it was
it was like let me let me post this
so people think like oh he's excited
he's happy and all that but like nah
deep down I'm like damn I don't want to
leave I I love here I love the fan base
I love the training staff I like the
coaching you know at that point they
just got uh just hired Frank Vogel
um and I wanted to play with Frank I had
a conversation you know a couple
conversations with him and I liked it
and I was just like I didn't want to
leave and it was kind of like smiling
through that and trying to put that
false
you know Macho front of like yeah I'm
good we hit we up baby because I think
it was interpreted by people because you
know Brandon Ingram had posted a smiling
emoji and then you had posted smiling
and I think most people interpret it as
you were happy to leave the Lakers but
you were saying it was a front of like I
wanted to stay and I wanna yeah it was a
it was sure with the front because I won
I wanted to say that like I I loved it
there um I loved the fans uh that fan
base is one of the best fan bases
um in the league and so so that was a
bummer to me but
you know looking bag at it yeah
obviously I get it I understand it
um I'm happy with you know the time that
I have there
um but that was something that like you
know I wasn't I wasn't ready for and
um
you know and obviously it's always it's
always tough you know obviously
um I for sure found out like when it for
sure happened obviously there was
different packages of you know trading
players and all that you know some came
out some didn't you know the ones that
came out I wasn't in I was like oh yeah
um and then it happened and I saw for
sure on Twitter what would you eat it
and I'm just like it's true yeah I'm
like yeah luckily I I had my podcast at
that point I was about to I was about to
record an episode with Kenneth Reed
and luckily he was uh deathly allergic
to dogs so
um so we didn't do it because if we did
my phone would have been on like
airplane mode nobody would yeah you
wouldn't have even known until like an
hour later so um
you know that happened but I was just
like man let me let me post this let me
let me fake like um like I'm excited I
like tweeted like we're we're the best
place to get beignets you know I mean I
was like tweeting it like you're like
I'm just lying like I'm happy like man
I'm playing myself dog I'm not trying to
leave I'm leaving L.A man I'm leaving
the purple and gold leaving this the the
sunshine yeah I'm leaving all that like
I don't want to leave that and the
people there I was extremely close with
like the training staff Nina Marco Stacy
those people there I'm like dog I don't
want to leave yeah so I had to try to
smile but look all things work out as
they should all things work out look at
you now you better get paid maybe you're
gonna find a real home exactly that's
all you need a nice nice home you know
you know if that's in New York it's
perfect hopefully they can figure out a
country club membership that I can get
into unless I can play so I can play
golf you know what I mean so do all the
things you love yeah so if there's any
country clubs in New York or anything
like that that want to you know
not even free but just you know let me
bypass that wait list
me in there yeah you know it doesn't
even have to be free you know I'll put
you know I'll put up some money you know
what I mean I've had a few so just just
let me just you know at the waitlist you
know a couple years let me slide up
number one on the waitlist I love our
fingers
um okay last one we ask everybody this
at the end of every episode
um what if you weren't an NBA player
what would you be doing
like I would love to be a Chelsea
football player oh my God okay so you
would just play soccer I'm playing
soccer I'm playing soccer I'm moving you
know obviously we didn't have the money
I'm over here talking about I had the
money to go to Chipotle and I'm like
yeah I would I would love for us to move
to London right but I would go you know
play on one of the best teams and like
the most popular sport in the world and
you could probably find like some of the
clips where I'm miked up and I I like
kicked the ball around before every game
that's like one of my rituals and I've
said it like yo I wish I could play
soccer like yeah
football like you did football
um I love that culture I love
um those kind of things if I wasn't that
um and it had nothing to do with sports
hmm
um
I don't know maybe like a commentator or
something like that that has to do with
sports yeah so that's something I'm like
damn I'm like damn if it's not Sports
uh uh I don't know maybe I'll be like an
accountant or something okay I like that
yeah
I have no idea like luckily and like
people now are gonna sit there you know
I'm 28
you know six years in the league I
always said I want to be down by like 35
so that's that puts me like six seven
more years oh yeah people like what do
you want to do after I'm like
maybe do like commentating or something
like that but honestly I have no idea so
the first year or two Yeah Boy the kids
are going to be old enough to be in
school hopefully the wife does something
hopefully at that point you are not a
museum she just wants me out the house
I'm playing golf every day I'm chilling
I'm gonna try to figure it out you would
be a good commentator though I just I
have to say thanks you really would like
I would be solid but if not I'm playing
golf I'm doing nothing I'm drinking wine
I'll have you over rehab hey I'm here
yeah we
here we go with a nice assortment of
cheeses
yeah exactly and then hopefully that can
be somewhere where it's like I want to I
want to raise kids in Maryland or
something but like I love let's do that
like summer Beach town like Hamptons
Manhattan Beach something like that
something worse is bougie but it's
simple boozy I can walk to the cheese
shop there's my sandals on you know what
I mean there's elements of non-business
even though it's overall exactly but I
don't have to feel like you know
everyone there is well off so I don't
feel like I have to like sit there in
front like I'm gonna sit there you know
with a you know over a white T-shirt
thong sandals or something like that and
people saying they're like oh hey Josh
yeah hey guys there you go wow you have
so much to look forward to I have to say
I told you once I'm done if I'm not
accommodating boy I'm having a simple
yet bougie life oh my God I can't wait I
have to say whatever it is you do you
absolutely deserve you are truly one of
my favorites you're so kind I don't know
if we have ever had somebody ask us if
we needed anything when we came he's
like Johnny drinks you need food I
wonder how you know be a good host you
know I mean yeah
probably the best host so thank you I
appreciate you coming on you are a joy
it has been really cool to just watch
you from Villanova to now you continue
to progress I wish you nothing but the
best I appreciate you coming on and I am
now going to give you something that you
never get
[Laughter]
my pleasure
foreign